mais SEP trucs pour tenir tes bonnes
résolutions sois réaliste prends pas 15
résolutions prendsant deux trois max
sois précis mais souple donne-toi des
objectifs concrets mesurables et clair
mais laisse-toi une marge de manœuvre
fais-toi aider il y a des trucs qu'on
peut pas bien faire tout seul plutôt que
de mal faire les choses et de risquer de
tout foirer bah il y a pas de honte à se
faire accompagner sois pas trop dur avec
toi-même être exigeant c'est bien être
intransigent c'est contreproductif
remotive-toi régulièrement quand tu sens
que tu faiblis rappelle-toi pourquoi tu
fais ça et ce que tu as à gagner
fais-toi plaisir tu te donnes du mal
donc pense à te féliciter déjà et puis
fais deux truc important compenser et te
récompenser et mon petit conseil bonus
prends pas de résolution janvier c'est
déjà le mois où on est tout et tout
super déprimé on va pas en plus se
charger la barque avec des trucs qu'on
s'empêche de faire ou qu'on s'oblige à
faire donc si tu le sens très bien mais
si tu le sens pas te force pas si tu as
envie de changer des trucs dans ta vie
tu peux le faire n'importe quand allez
bonne année